bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france votre regard tout
d'abord rémi tales sur la mobilisation
de ce samedi une mobilisation données en
baisse par le ministère de l'intérieur
vous en pensez quoi
visiblement bien sûr l'intérieur on a
des problèmes de vue la première semaine
bien sûr on a des chiffres ont été
divisés par fois par 45 70 et non pour
avoir fait les manifestations depuis
de nombreuses semaines maintenant je
dire qu'il ait plus de monde aujourd'hui
la semaine dernière naissance est
présent à ce rendez vous dire leur
opposition à la ségrégation pour leur
dire leur opposition à ce ce monde de
contrôle social et dire leur souhait de
voir en clans s'étaient sérieusement de
coronavirus
et des moments de mourir alors pourquoi
minimiser les chiffres de cette
manifestation des mitaines
c'est toujours le jeu actuel vous avez
une contestation dans la rue ça aurait
été ou giedré sg 1 si les chiffres à peu
près qu'on tombe à l'arrivée des avis
communiqué ça permet de s'y croire qu'on
serait qu'une minorité extrémiste excité
dans ces rassemblements vous les profils
il vient de plus les horizons politiques
qui pour certains d'entre eux sont
vaccinés sont non vaccinés mais qui
partagent cette inquiétude sur l'état de
nos libertés et le chemin que prend la
cohésion nationale dans notre pays au
prétexte encore une fois qu'ils ont vécu
je suis toujours de prêter
commencez-vous pierre-jean ternat mion
de cette mobilisation aujourd'hui mais
celle aussi des dès samedi précédent à
travers la france contre donc se passe
sanitaire et ce qu'elle a une légitimité
à vos yeux
en pour moi l'an n'a aucune ne s'est
s'impliqué partisans on va dire d'avoir
un pass à lithaire dès l'an dernier mais
je pense qu'on aurait dû rendre la
vaccination obligatoire prenez l'exemple
de la nouvelle calédonie ils ont
maintenant réaliser que la prochaine
étape après on va dire
la polynésie française c'est eux donc
résultat l'ensemble des besoins des
responsables de la nouvelle calédonie
ont décrété vaccination obligatoire
c'est leur seule chance d'éviter les
situations qu'on est en train de vivre à
la martinique à la guadeloupe où vous
avez un patient karibe où lui fait un
scanner et en fonction de ces lésions
vous lui dites vous expliquer la famille
que vous ne pourrez pas le réanimer
c'était une médecine de guerre qui se
passe actuellement aux antilles et ça
c'est inacceptable
je dirais pour une population qui a
droit des soins et une protection
limitée le coc répondez-vous à
pierre-jean ternen deux ans sur le fait
qu'une vaccination obligatoire aurait dû
déjà être mises en place depuis
longtemps
je vraiment efficace la vaccination
généralisée est obligatoire en israël on
a une vague on n'a jamais vraiment
si on rapporte le sont quotidiennes ou
serait population sache et sans nous et
sigean qui seront
réanimation ronis
doublement
donc il faut ajouter
la santé avec est connu quelques-uns ont
rejeté tout libéral n'est chère de
contrefaire deux groupes sous d'ailleurs
en scène
la troisième dose ne suffira pas ça la
quatrième il ya du traitement
pense évidemment
qui a permis à alain
de la pandémie et quant à la
mère
seuls quelques le réanimation sont
lorsque les cliniques opposé leurs raids
les patients en situation le prêt chez
nous et luca
et donc la liberté
est justement pardon 28 oh peut-être
mais malheureusement
approchant on intel rémi tales on vous
entend
très mal on vous entend un peu ans
hachad et on va vous laisser régler
votre micro en attendant je je me tourne
vers vous pierre-jean ternes amian
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement a adopté la bonne stratégie
face à ces manifestations ne cédant pas
sur le passe à lithaire et la
vaccination obligatoire pour certains
corps de métiers
oui bien sûr e
le pass à lithaire permet si vous voulez
d'être sûr que les gens sont protégés
qui protège des autres en étant vacciner
pour le court ismaël ces faits cinq
mises ont été très en avance sur la
vaccination
la vaccination de direct de la grippe
c'est chaque année à l'automne pour y
arriver il se trouve que l'on gagne on
n'a pas de grippe mais qui est chaque
année on doit se rebeller contre la
grippe et on arrive pratiquement au bout
d'un an on va dire pour des personnes
qui sont effectivement essentiellement
âgé au début on y aille avec des
facteurs de comorbidité et on sait que
l'immunité sc liée à l'âge
donc on n'a pas le choix s'il voulait il
faut refaire une dose à terme pour
maintenir un niveau de protection pour
la population rurale et le pass
sanitaire participent à des claques six
nations à une protection de la
population française
rémi tales vous pensez que le
gouvernement va céder face à la
mobilisation contre le bassin sanitaire
alors il ya plusieurs aspects à cette
initiation vous avez la mobilisation
dans la rue c'est ce qui effectivement
on a fait encore aujourd'hui vous avez
le boycott de tous les secteurs
économiques qui mettent en oeuvre le
pass and i ter en -70 % de fréquentation
dans les cinémas c'est un désastre dans
les x et le medef aujourd'hui demandent
le retrait du pass sanitaires dans les
grands centres commerciaux et son
abandon au plus vite pour le reste de
l'économie donc nous avons des moyens
d'agir et je ne doute pas que le
gouvernement sera bien obligé par un
moment de de prendre en considération le
l'inquiétude des français le passé ni
terre n'a pas aidé en place en france en
revanche
dans une situation vraiment de 2 c le
particulier de la part du gouvernement
sur ce passé sanitaire je ne peux pas
croire qu'il tiendra savelli les
situations de ségrégation d'injustice ne
dure jamais longtemps google un sens ça
partira mais il faut que ça passe que le
plus vite possible parce qu'on parlait
des soins vous avez des personnes
traitées pour des maladies chroniques
par exemple des cancers qui aujourd'hui
se voir refuser l'accès à l'hôpital
lorsque des messages tous les jours
absolument absolument terrifiant et donc
ça aussi c'est une menace pour la santé
publique
car jean terrain d'amiens vous en pensez
quoi vous fait que certaines personnes
enfin et pour les personnes du moins qui
n'ont pas de passes anita ne puisse pas
se faire soigner c'est normal
donc c'est pas vrai c'est absolument pas
vrai je dirais on est dans une situation
où
on est et on a jugulé la quatrième vague
par la vaccination elle passe sanitaires
on n'est plus du tout dans le temps on
va dire la première vin qu'on a connus
au printemps de nous
là actuellement
vous n'avez aucune fermeture d'accès
pour les patients et la première règle
pour un médecin c'est que vous ayez un
pass and it héros pas vous revenez le
patient ça c'est une premier point c'est
vers un diplôme par contre sur les
pathologies chroniques
la situation actuelle vague permet
effectivement de de les prendre en
charge sans retard et on essaye ça
arrive de plus en plus à rattraper on va
dire que le stock qu'on va dire
m'appelle heureusement qu'on avait pu
obliger on va lire d'avoir à ce qu'on
appelait des lits de réanimation plein
ou de post opératoire mais le problème
va pas celui là le problème c'est la
vaccination à terme des enfants pourquoi
parce que la quatrième vague sans les
tenir et on est très inquiet pour les
quinze jours qui arrivent dans trois
semaines où vous aurez un brassage de
population avec les enfants qui sont
effectivement porteur sain souvent mais
qui vont aller de nouveau contaminés on
risque d'avoir à arbon là la grande
inconnue elle est là dans les trois
semaines c'est est ce qu'on aura une
robe de la vague ou pas
merci beaucoup pierre-jean père damian
pour toutes ces précisions je rappelle
que vous êtes radiologues et le rps
médecins libéraux ronald et merci à vous
rend-elle cofondateur du collectif
peuple libre